family members of george floyd are
expected to testify early
next week for the prosecution as the
derek chauvin murder trial
enters its third week in minneapolis
that's the word of an attorney for the
floyd family
it follows friday's testimony from the
hennepin county chief medical examiner
who performed the autopsy to determine
the cause of floyd's death
jamie yukas reports the medical examiner
who performed the autopsy on george
floyd took the stand
dr andrew baker told jurors that while
heart disease and drugs played a role
it was the interaction with police that
caused floyd's death
the law enforcement subdual restraint
and the neck compression was just more
than mr floyd could take by virtue of
those heart conditions on the death
certificate dr baker listed the drugs
found in floyd's system
and heart ailments as contributing
conditions not
causes mr floyd's use of fentanyl did
not cause
the subduel or neck restraint his heart
disease did not cause
the subduel or the neck restraint but
during cross-examination the defense
continued to focus on floyd's drug use
you're aware also of the methamphetamine
that was found in
mr floyd's system yes i'm not an expert
in
the specific toxicology of
methamphetamine as a general rule
for forensic pathology methamphetamine
is not good for a damaged heart
this was not a sudden death forensic
pathology expert lindsey thomas is a
former county medical examiner who
trained baker
she testified floyd died from asphyxia
or low oxygen
terms not mentioned in baker's autopsy
report
the activities of the law enforcement
officers resulted in mr floyd's death
meanwhile minneapolis residents are
following the trial closely
yeah you can just sit here pastor edwin
williams has been listening to the
concerns
of his predominantly black neighborhood
i'm absolutely afraid that if
if a non-guilty verdict or some sort of
technicality is used to
to keep the officer from facing
responsibility for this that we'll see
worse than what we saw last summer the
trial is moving quicker than originally
thought so the prosecution is now
expected to rest its case
early next week all eyes will then turn
to the defense
and whether or not chauvin will testify
for cbs this morning saturday
jamie yukas minneapolis